aber wir haben jetzt eine neue tanz
humba humba humba hallöchen liebe
freunde und herzlich willkommen zurück
zu captain minecraft teil 3 zusammen mit
komme und erst mal hinkommen hallöchen
popöchen wir haben in der letzten folge
relativ viel geschafft und zwar haben
wir also ich kann sich mal so zeigen
über den tab command bla wir haben
insgesamt schon einiges erreicht die
wakeboarder schon ein ganzes stück
weiter aber das ist ja immer so zu
anfang geht es richtig richtig ab ich
hab fackeln gefunden und ich würde sagen
wir machen jetzt in dieser folge direkt
mal was cooles und zwar nehme ich mir so
eine charcoal und wir haben ja sieben
eisen das lohnt sich auch und jetzt
meine lieben freunde haben wir eventuell
wieder schnell zu ruhm war es das am
anfang mit dem inventar in einer folge
gewesen
aber wir haben jetzt einen neuen tanz
humba humba humba humba humba humba
humba und jetzt müssen wir überlegen wo
es einen bekannten kids zu sein
oben weiß ich das alleine ist aber hier
sind wir haben nämlich auch entdeckt
hier bin ich ja in der ersten folge
sport als ich gestorben war
aber das war relativ doofer ich habe
mich dann zurück gepostet das war aber
nicht aber nicht notwendig gewesen weil
das alles nur über uns war und man kann
der eventuell wieder hoch gehen einfach
und ich schaue es mal ganz kurz ob wir
irgendwelche neuen thron auferlegt sind
sich irgendwas verändert hatte aber
bisher eigentlich noch nicht ich will
einfach nichts schön fleißig am angeln
will hier mein leben hier unten im
becken und warte darauf dass ein fisch
anbeißt
ja der in das netz quasi perfekte zeit
um auf thema einzugehen allerdings
nutzen kommen und ich derzeit nur
twitter um gegenseitig zitate bei uns
aus ich habe fischer kein eis sind brate
ich meine stelle haben wir nämlich den
erfolg beeil dich am besten fertig bitte
ganz ganz schnell wenn man moderne
brennt die kohle noch ja ich komme ich
komm ich komme mir lösen syndikat aus
die krones aus und wir hätten vielleicht
die kohle kohle reichte immer für
8 und 17 1 getan so wahrscheinlich
anbraten schon was gebracht
am besten erstmal können wir das nicht
mehr wichtig machen oder so aber ich
möchte am berler kamp mit ja mit mit dem
holz werkzeug aber das brauchen wir
eventuell noch oder und nehmen
ich weiß nicht mal irgendwas rein wir
das spiel komme es ist hart die schüsse
rein oder schüssel sicht unnötig oliver
vor wochen das geht nicht ob man kommt
ja auch einfach mal rein
ok man kann nicht mehr ich würde
eigentlich so griff ich hab mich schwer
reingepackt vollidiot und es geht ihr
dadurch aber achtung macht dich warm für
den home button ich mal nicht fahren da
manchmal nicht wahr
oh ja humba humba humba humba humba
humba humba und soll ich sage was ich
gemeint finde du hast den erfolg dafür
bekommen weil ich den fisch ausgenommen
du bist direkt weggelaufen weil du die
kohle dar ein gelöster der letzten folge
ganz einfach ich weiß wo du four death
and vorstadt wo finde ich nicht und an
das tue einfach den erfolg bekommen aber
hier ist auch schon wieder richtig viel
eisen
also ich denke wir können uns gleich
schon eisen schwert und eisen eine
ersten spitzhacke machen das glaube ich
wichtiger und sag mir mal bitte wie wir
es mit der nahrung machen wer fische
wollen wir die schon essen natürlich
erstmal braten aber wollen wir die dann
essen oder wenn wir noch warten damit
oder wie es das essen braten essen
warten
ich bin mir nicht sicher wie wir das mit
der nahrung machen wollen
ich möchte bei den ganzen sache nicht so
vorsichtig wie nur möglich irgendwie
vorgehen
ach du hast du denn alles scho gefunden
da unten da oben
da war eine truhe also in dieser zeit
kann man muss sogar noch mehr kohle
gefunden das heißt wie viele fische
haben wir dann könntest du dir schon mal
braten danke ich immer ein bisschen auf
erkundungstour
ach so dann gibt man bitte die kohle wir
haben nämlich ganze neun fische mit
diesem rohrlack sich lieber nicht parat
weise hat eine andere farbe hat
irgendwie vielleicht braucht man dann
später noch so das war keine gute idee
ich brauche meine kohle ja einen moment
habe ich so viel eisen gefunden so ich
geh jetzt hier einfach mal cool 14
eisern eine kohle im rat das irgendwie
und braten locker nicht für was ein
stück kohle reicht für acht stück eisen
ein stück kohle reicht für acht fischer
dem neuen feature das reicht es ja dass
putin gibt er dann noch einen fisch ich
habe glaube ich schon essen
da wäre ich auch für wir können uns aber
auch erstmal ausloten fleisch noch
konzentrieren ich jetzt erstmals roten
fleisch und dann würde ich sagen wenn
ich dann gleich wieder voll gesättigt
bin heute versteht hier dran purple
saint clair und diesmal müssen wir ganz
vorsichtig umgehen mit solchen sachen
wie beispielsweise nach rose oder so das
ist halt dass das einzige wo ich sage da
müssen uns verbessern sonst haben wir
alles in cap dass zwei gut gemeistert
eigenlob dann muss ich sagen da kann
werde ich ganz gut durch muss man sagen
ein lob an uns so er ich habe schon
wieder kohle gefunden übrigens während
schnyder fünf kohle
das heißt zum braten am besten nur kohle
benutzen und eventuell unsere alten
schwerter und so wenn wir uns in sachen
aus holz machen aussage normalnull kohle
verwenden fisch braten
ich nehme die krone daraus und
verbrachte erst mal das wurden sword was
wir da noch haben eine weitere tour
gefunden
cool ja mit möchtest du hochkommen und
selber gucken oder soll ich sagen ist es
um besonders der sache einfach also wer
mir sechs kohle ein apfel und live afl
samen bekommen damit vielleicht wieder
ein baum lag aber nicht an
aus dem apfel links bekommen man schätze
können wir daraus machen
aha stimmt ja deswegen das wertvoll
ich verrate gerade übrigens sich nutzer
als brennstoff gerade nicht kohle
sondern unsere alten wurden werkzeuge du
kannst einfach mal in den ofen
reinschauen und ja schon ich habe schon
etwas für dich komme hier sehr schlau
es gibt einfach mal vier stück und ich
behalte nur zwei weil ich so ein netter
mensch bin auch dass noch eine
wir müssten ich frag mich wann wir das
erste mal heißt es erde finden noch mal
schauen aber sehr schlau von dir dass du
die truhe da unten hin gemacht hast wie
gesagt wenn hier in kryta kommt ein
problem deswegen ich mach mal eben die
gänge hier dicht so lassak okay ich
packe jetzt erstmal den restlichen fisch
den ich erst mal ich brauche da rein
fackeln brauche ich ja auch erstmal
nicht sieben eisen haben wir und da
wartet das kann man aus dem all seines
machen das haben wir schon choir
hardware diamonds nächste patch ein
kugelfisch den haben wir auch dem lot
apple auch dieses mit dem skelett töten
will wieder so interessant eine kuh ja
samen bekommen wir wahrscheinlich in die
aus dem ried sind die samen bekommen wir
gleich wahrscheinlich irgendwann aber
auch mehr als erde gucken wir mal noch
weiter bei den chiefs menz zucker dafür
brauchen wird dies andere hier haben wir
auch schon alles taken wir müssen jetzt
quasi einfach mal weiter erkunden
genau und eventuell mal schauen dass das
ganze mit sich bringt ich komme jetzt
einfach mal mit ich mache jetzt mal eben
ein tolles schwerte
ja warum wir denn irgendwie holz oder so
ich nehme einfach mal das output place
weil ich finde diese akazienholz wenn
ich irgendwie viel schöner
ja finde ich auch solche auch eine tolle
schnäppchen machen
ja mach mal gerne doch da ist wirklich
dafür verloren
hier kommen wir haben so viel reisen
schwer dem man gönnt sich ja sonst
nichts im leben richtig sowas und
spitzhacke ebenso ich hab eine truhe
gefunden keiner ist und da sind ganz
viele boote drin und ein buch mit
verzaubertes buch ordnung drei geil da
machen wir mit dem eisen gleich zwei
eisen helm und dann bin ich auch
schniegler distanz hat er noch nicht
aufmachen wer noch keinen ein amboss ich
weiß aber dass die oma ist aber den
können wir erst erreichen den drei
erfolgen oder so ok bitte runter
du hast wieder unsere tun nicht beachtet
mit den wertvollen sachen und so wenig
komme es ist erklärt zum beispiel auch
wertvoll bei dieser map das muss man
echt sagen ich hab was für dich oh danke
schön billig
ich nehme mal eben fisch mit und dann
sollen wir die welt ein bisschen
erkunden gerne gegen sie mich nehmen wir
zwei fackeln mit ohne redstone fackel
falls ihr unter wasser muss jetzt gehen
wir mal ein bisschen hoch hier genau zu
den sportlern mal ein paar monster töten
dann hier auf guck mal hier
wenn man hier raten den war das war
nicht die natürliche links links und
nicht gut weil wir anders hier vorne
eine etage über uns doch komme jetzt
auch wieder sein preis marin kristall
weil leute alle die die letzte folge
nicht mehr geschaut habe diese prismen
kristalle braucht man mit der zeit auch
wieder einer um die verschollene stadt
atlantis erneut zum leuchten zu bringen
ich gehe wir können auch einfach die
treppe hochgehen kann man hier sind auch
wieder press marin kristalle er ganz
cool wenn du dir auch mal mit muss
kommen und ich ließ da kommt keys aus
dem kies können wir feuerstein machen
das auch wieder ein bisschen kristalle
kommen sieht es wieder nicht ab die
kohle dafür gesehen gerade immer die
spurs mit zack da hab ich auch so ein
kristall uli brée richtig level punkte
die christen und setzten die blöcke die
du dadurch bekommt wieder dahin
damit das ganze land ein bisschen show
oder sind willkommen du bist gut
informiert da wollte ich gar nicht hin
so waren der amboss ich war ja gerade
bei am besten bei wievielen kristalle
gibt es denn auf dieser map ich finde so
viele alter sind die viel obst kann man
entscheiden
ja stimmt schon also ohne eisen
schwerter wäre es tausendfach
schwieriger können wir den sportlern ich
meine wir ausleuchten dass wir gleich
mal irgendwie die ganze franken dabei
ich hatte ja ja so eine mitgenommen
prima vista ich kann mir welche machen
warten mal ja nimmer welche mit am
besten so also jetzt bei mir auch schon
die spinnen gott alter ist ein bisschen
traurig dass man dieses resort pack
benutzen muss wird es keinen zweck
spielen sodass borders ausgeleuchtet und
kommt wieder die kiste hier oben nicht
mitgenommen management ma lin china aber
ausleuchten was sollen waffen ist
richtiger rowdy hier die kiste war lea
und die standard noch so wie eigentlich
mal für die mieten schon mal hier hegau
das ist meine geheime kammer nur bitte
bescheid weißt du bist gefangen alter
der sind schon drin werden kann machen
müssen aber egal wer mein genug steine
du bist gut um treffen du blöder peter
richtig ab ich einmal richtig so weit
kommt da auch listen tür herzen alter
als verlegen wir unter gefallen
von wo kommt die baby zombies die kommt
von irgendwo hier oben debattiert und
wenn ich dieses loch durchgefallen wo du
das nicht zugebaut ist kommt ihm merkte
ich das ist neben aber lebenswichtig
lebens richtig wichtig richtig süchtig
nach ihm geht es eigentlich auch wenn
ich das so ablehne da machen eventuell
noch ein schwert um diese seite nachher
abzubauen damit man daraus wolle machen
können und blablabla wir könnten rein
theoretisch mal die decke kaputt machen
damit er mal das wasser runter kommt und
wir wieder hoch schwimmen können da oben
wo man wo ich in der mitte
aber mit denen der abbauen wie sowieso
denn damit wir da hinkommen
ich würde sagen erst mal nicht treppe
vielleicht euro komplett runter gefallen
einmal alter krug berlin
das gibt rache ich komme wieder schnell
wieder auf da ich will ich wäre dafür
dass wir uns alle seine kleine
individuelle treppe bauen bevor wir
jetzt irgendwie dass das ganze wasser
unterspült weit ich ja meine ich
deswegen schon okay du hast ja so ein
paar ok schön macht der super danke
danke
nee ich möchte noch spannender sein man
kann nämlich hieraus solche half snaps
machen und das liegt dann vielleicht
warte bleiben unten stehe nicht die
steine fallen ist wieder runter dann
hast du ein bisschen mehr corbis tokio
danke schön hast du dann mache ich hier
habe ich da mache ich daraus mal
einmalig so ein pass labs ich sehe auch
schon wieder von chris martin kristalle
und den hole ich mir auch erst mal
wieder heben
hast du die fische dabei die ich
gebracht habe ja ich habe zwei fische
dabei aber die muss ich selber gleich
ersten weil ich selber total am form bin
und was passiert da unten sind glaube
ich noch welche
ach da ja sonst immer noch wir haben
immer noch robbenfleisch fast kaputt
echt jetzt mal gut aber du hast schon
viel gegraben ich habe schon richtig
viel was man die kristalle mitgenommen
so ich komm mal hoch da bauen wir die
treppe weiter hinein zombies lernen
macht da sich waren in minecraft ich
meine birne hinzugefügt wird dann bin
ich ja so froh wir können auch einfach
diesen nenner bringt er abbauen
theoretisch weil macht's gut sagt machst
du so wollte ich nicht hin ich bau ne
treppe haye aber ich kann ihr keinen
bock science runter machen
das war dumm aber die sieht voll schöner
aus franken jetzt können wir von hier
war noch nicht klar da muss mal wieder
in greiz machen wo wir das schöner
machen
ich beschütze immer so ein bisschen hier
das village apa die burg und jetzt kann
man hier hoch wir sind wo bin ich denn
hier gelandet wo ihr seid willkommen in
meiner schönen hülle hier ist jetzt aber
direkt wieder an zombies bonner nächte
da sich wieder press marin kristall ich
hab eine fackel dabei die bringt
wahrscheinlich viel aber immerhin hält
zumindest ein bisschen licht
ich habe meine spitze gesehen moment
knapp clay gefunden
echt eine spitzhacke kaputt er gute
kannst ja auch ohne spitzer car porn ja
bereits abgefunden
das trifft mich jetzt um chris martin
kristall komme das ist schön dass wir so
gut vorankommen volk mischt er wir sind
diesmal finde ich nicht übervorsichtig
aber vorsichtig zugleich sind so gute
mittel press marin christian aber das
war doch nicht du ich hole mir gerade
die tonnenweise kokain als richtig gut
dann kann man sich mental endlich mal
rüstung machen weil ein amboss hast du
wirklich schon gesehen dass auch noch
als ja ich schon gesehen der war hier
schön aber zwei erfolge entfernt ja das
laufen das ist ja kein ding da machen
aber das ist aber echt schön dass wir
uns diesmal kein anders bauen müssen wir
da haben wir viel mehr als ich hier über
dir sind abriss marin kristalle da ja
man habe halt viel mehr eisen und seiner
rüstung zu machen und dass wir nicht
immer so oft sterben
was sind das überhaupt hierfür blöcke
prisma
prisma regel kann man die umwandeln ich
bin mir nicht sicher
ich weiß nicht ob man die später auch
blaue brauche ich glaube schon aber
steht aber sagen wir bewegen uns mal
wieder zurück in unsere schöne base hier
lagen die gute idee und dann wird habe
ich hab moment ich hab mir gravel
gefunden
ja wer also dings greven links dann
rechts schön aber eigentlich auch noch
sein traum hier werde ich so viel eisen
mittlerweile wer mehr eisen als holz
sagt das nicht so laut ich wette gleich
wenn so viele alben kommen will
ich bin nicht ich will nicht noch nicht
die treppe runter laufen eben reisen
geholt warum denn mit draußen
entschärfen
folge ist für ende mich folge beenden
was soll ich denn da gefunden
übrigens danke an henry dass er nicht
den fehler gemacht hat mich dass ich das
wieder vergessen zehn folgen lang der
als das wo bist du
danke danke ich bin auf dem weg nach
unten ja so wirklich bist du der
minecraft land kurs hat und zwar wie ein
server zur verfügung gestellt wer nicht
von ihr auf bike exif einzelnen 2 und 3
jetzt auch er hat auch eine aktie zu
hause ok also dir die world border ist
hier kommt es mir sofort als jene die es
nicht weitergegangen das ist noch sehr
ausgehöhlt pensionen aber ich weiß nicht
wie können das ganze auf jeden fall
richtig cool gestalten ich hätte zum
beispiel auch mal wieder bock gegen ende
des projekts auf den live stream
aber das kommt natürlich alles noch wenn
es euch gefallen hat würden wir uns über
eine bewertung freuen
die nächste folge kommen morgen bei ghom
auf dem kanal wo wir dann oben weiter
umschauen und rum buddeln und eventuell
noch mehr clay finden und an ein neues
moment machen und was weiß ich alles
kann bekomme begutachten und dann würde
ich sagen tschüss meine lieben freunde
autorin jetzt schiller